every day of this shoot
we're making something new and special
jordan peele takes a completely
different approach on the set of his
newest horror movie
and something that is a testament to why
i love movies and i'll be talking about
these days we made this movie forever
jordan peele's nope gives us a fresh
take on the classic genres of horror and
sci-fi with his iconic writing and
directing an incredible imax budget and
a legendary cinematographer nope brings
a deep thought-provoking message to life
with stellar visuals and captivating
performances to match
number one we're here for whatever
vision he wants to put on the screen
jordan peele's vision for this film was
to make it like an introduction to
horror for people who wouldn't typically
watch it like an open invitation this
movie will be scary but at the very
least i'm bringing you in the title nope
signifies the group of people who would
never in a million years be in a
situation that the film represents let
alone watch it on screen there's certain
things that are just going to make us go
nope it's done number two the complexity
behind it is more natural than you'd
think jordan peele's directing style is
actually pretty collaborative when it
comes to creating the characters the
most impressive thing about jordan is
that he allows the story to kind of find
itself the actors found their
character's intentions changing minute
by minute the more the story would
unfold to kind of be welcomed into a
very collaborative environment like that
is a huge blessing number three
speaking of building characters jordan
actually did let me improv a lot which
is really cool the great thing about
kiki palmer's character emerald is that
she was written in such a natural way
that her energy and comedic talent
popped off the screen what was written
of the character emerald was uh so much
what i like to play with in terms of my
comedic wheelhouse when jordan gave kiki
the script it was clear to her that he'd
already had her in mind when writing it
number four
jordan peele's impact on the horror
genre is legendary and i appreciate what
he does for our culture across the board
and just giving us these beautiful
pieces of representation kiki palmer has
played so many characters throughout her
career but with emerald's natural hair
and shamelessly real demeanor she turned
out to be one of the most meaningful for
her to play the kind of chick i get to
play you know it's the kind of character
that i feel like usually only guys get
to play number five an emotional scene
takes a comedic turn one of the great
things about working with horses is that
they don't really care if you're in the
middle of a scene if they have to go
they're going it's like a really
emotional scene i'm letting that lucky
go and then lucky just decided to do a
piss
the irony is not lost here and it was a
really long piece and i just had to wait
there
number six a simple farm town that holds
a lot of meaning to the film's
characters the amount of work and detail
and effort that went into constructing
that town is pretty insane jup's theme
park jupiter's claim was built in the
aguadusa desert which is a real place in
los angeles county as far as what it
represents in the film dupe is held
metaphorically prisoner even though he
built it all for himself this is his
nightmare this is his fever dream this
is his prison in every detail there are
hidden pockets of darkness the truth is
a lot simpler and darker than we could
ever imagine number seven especially for
a 65 million dollar imax movie jordan
peele describes this movie as a standout
from his other films i tried to write a
script that i didn't know how to pull it
off and then assemble the team to help
me pull it off as we mentioned before
jordan is a huge collaborator when it
comes to his filmmaking he wants
everyone to have a voice
every single department is firing off
these huge big swings
it was important for him to create an
environment where every person involved
is able to speak up and put forth their
own creative imprint we're all important
individually and in combination for all
of us is hugely important number eight
just like emerald jordan peel wrote oj
with daniel kaluuya in mind in an
interview with empire he describes his
character as a humble man destined for
an epic and otherworldly confrontation
he also speaks on why daniel was the
perfect person to play the role daniel's
craft is on a different level but it's
his warmth that grounds audiences even
during points of absolute madness
you may be watching a nightmare but when
he's on screen at least you've got your
brother with you and that's all you need
number nine it's very subtle but it's
there the underlying message for the
film all started when one of the
producers gave jordan a book on edward
muybridge godfather of motion picture
for you know some of these experimental
photography
that he took this was the first door
that opened up the exploration of the
film industry and all of the
exploitation that has always been part
of it that became an underlying theme
that is i think woven throughout the the
film not only that but there are several
other important underlying themes
throughout the movie let us know in the
comments which ones jumped out at you
number 10 we're talking consultations
with actual jellyfish experts jordan
peele worked with john dibiri an
aeronautics engineer and the centennial
chair professor at caltech as well as
the director of the biological
propulsion laboratory so yeah he
definitely knows a thing or two about
creating a massive ufo alien jellyfish
that jellyfish known as jean jacket
utilizes features of real marine life
throughout the film tibiary spoke with
thrillists about his inspirations it has
all of these interesting properties
about looking at it in the eye that
metamorphosis that it has in the end
going from more conventional ufo flying
saucer shape and at the end revealing
itself
number eleven though gordy the chimp
story is painfully tragic it's also
based on the real life story of a chimp
named travis we won't get into it here
but the story of gordy shares a major
lesson on the treatment of animals for
spectacle though in this film the chimp
was portrayed by actor terry notary who
is no stranger to this type of role he
also played rocket in planet of the apes
number 12 the film opens up with a major
cinema fact the very first assembly of
photographs to create a motion picture
was a two second clip of a black man on
a horse the only fictional thing about
it in the movie is his identity as
emerald's great great great grandfather
great there's another great grandfather
but in real life his true identity is no
longer known
number 13 but originally he wasn't
actually supposed to in an interview
with scifi brandon perea who plays angel
shared that his character not only does
it make it through the first draft but
also the second jordan was definitely in
a mode of let's wreck these people and
i'm like no man don't wreck me though
after talking to some of the studio
heads they all came to the consensus
that they needed angel until the very
end number 14. also known as the
alternate title apparently jordan peele
only thought of calling the movie nope
well into the pre-production stage of
the film but the title he was writing
with was little green men at the end of
the day the film felt singular and nope
was the only thing that i could i could
say to describe it because the film is
about among several other things greed
the little green men represent the men
on our dollar bills number fifteen we're
not promising any ufos but we have to
mention the fact that universal studios
reconstructed the park as part of its
studio tour on the hollywood backlot
universal even built an entire website
and social media profiles before the
movie premiered all of which were
entirely fictional but if you saw before
the film you'd think it was a totally
real theme park considering one of the
film's major themes is about spectacle
again the irony is not lost on us
so after going through all the
inspirations character collaborations
mishaps and the true stories behind
another one of jordan peel's brilliant
creations we're honestly just excited
for what he's gonna do next what are
some of your favorite moments from the
film